hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to office freakout now if
you know me you know that I am never one
to get angry I never lose control I
never fly off the handle and I very
rarely raise my voice so this game is
about getting angry which is something
that I don't understand so I thought
it'd be a good opportunity for the sweet
innocent baby boy that I am to try to
imagine a little anger why not let me
try my best here let me let me try
alright here we go
I'm on Oh welcome to reboot computer
repair cubical workplace where many
employees throw their lives away doing
tediously soul-sucking data entry tasks
for the rest of their lives however it
is currently after work hours and of
course Philbert is still here slaving
away as demanded by his manager or Phil
Berg you're fired we wish you the best
of luck on your future endeavors I'll
clean out your guys uh-oh
filbert was just fired it looks like he
has hit his breaking point
Dilbert is going crazy no will no
control yourself like it's time to
finally rage here we go
Phil it's our thinking Zim oh yeah Danis
today we will be going over what to do
when a fellow employees overcome by
office roam those going through an
office freakout exhibit an undying rage
and the ability to break things to the
point they no longer physically exist
those undergoing an office freakout
often recollect seeing small colored
orbs they compulsively collect clay left
on the mouse to punch hold shift to
unleash a power attack destroyed objects
drop point orbs that will fill your
destruction bar they have also been
observed picking up core defenseless
office supplies and using the best
weapons or cruelly placing them gently
on the ground right-click an objective
pick it up
use left click to attack right-click
again to throw or Ft to drop if they
continue office freaking out they may
enter into a rage those in a rage will
unleash the fold devastating potential
of your average middle-aged cubicle
worker this naturally includes the
ability to spontaneously generate
powerful weapons from thin air
destroying things quick enough will fill
up your rage bar allowing you to enter
rage mode filling it again will equip
your rage weapon fill it a third time to
earn twice the points Oh
if the need arises the emergency exit
elevator will activate simply find the
exit key once you have reached the
minimum destruction milestone the key
will appear on a golden object in the
level follow the compass to the golden
key once it's appeared on the map
destroy it to get the key
leave the level quickly and you will be
awarded bonus points oh you can stay and
continue your rampage to earn higher
scores until time runs out remember in
order to beat the level you must have
the exit key in order to be successful
or you will be locked in the office for
eternity remember employees every
replacement comes from your paycheck oh
well then why would I do that oh I guess
I'm fired so I'm not getting any
paycheck so whatever man
okay I'm looking bad huh rawr rawr I'm a
bombed angry boy I mean I'm an angry man
I'm angry get ready here comes my here
comes a thunder I'm about to unleash the
beast that is nice
how do I there got it
oh hello ah
yeah Jesus punching things hurts
ma oh I got one an orb went into my body
I feel strange ha I I have some serious
grievances about the working conditions
in this office I think that we should
have better coffee and more frequent
breaks also I probably shouldn't have
been fired but I'll fight for the other
employees now I suppose I'll probably
end up paying for this because I feel
bad right now I'm angry oh you're gonna
get it next David I was always upsetting
you and so much food and never shared it
with me that was really mean of you you
should have been more considerate of
other people's feelings uh-oh
take these uh terrible airplanes whoosh
oh you're gonna get it Huff whoosh
somehow that happened I don't know how
oh gosh something tells me I may have
more power than I realized
like when like when Superman first
realized that he was actually not human
and an alien and probably didn't belong
here this amount of wanton destruction
seems to be working me a little bit I
mean I'm not entirely sure that I should
be you know doing this oh god I'm in a
rage whew I'm really angry now
ah the computers were always slow and
getting here was always too heavy and
traffic I was like an hour commute back
and forth oh it's really getting me
angry now
I'm gonna unleash a power attack well
Boosh key well bass key boom key okay I
did it
I think ha Dustbuster I'm gonna hoof it
and get a high so that you guys don't
think that I am so angry
okay hey no oh my boss is a bit of a
dick his deadlines are too shortened and
also II he pays me too little oh so
little that I don't make any because I
am fired oh this seems like it actually
might be lethal so I don't know if I
should have this but huh oh I'll pay for
that I'm sorry
go geez I'm sorry Oh God although
Susie's desk oh [ __ ] in retrospect you
know I feel like I could have talked to
a therapist about this and it would have
been a healthier outlet for all of my
unbridled rage I mean girl bang grieger
I think at this point I should probably
leave I I think I've cleared out enough
stuff I hope this is all tax-deductible
I'm just destroying these scissors
because it's dangerous for the work
environment and I want all my fellow
co-workers to be safe and and feel cared
for really what all I want even though
I'm I seem to be very good at stabbing
this in a shanking motion I really want
everyone to just be happy with their
lives
I mean gir oh there's something there
oh oh I I should probably report the
fact that I've discovered demon magic to
HR because I'm pretty sure this is
irresponsible I'm just doing this to
test it out Oh God
I am so sorry I am so sorry this is a
fire hazard I should alert the fire
department right away but I'm pretty
sure if I try to drop this fireball it's
gonna it's gonna burn everybody alive
and probably and there's no one here so
I don't want to risk my own life I'm
gonna try to put it out stop [ __ ] man
oh god oh Jesus oh god what have I done
I don't know I can I leave oh geez if I
just leave uh-oh
I'm sorry I did it I did good though I
think I actually felt the anger boiling
up through me right right right behind
all the remorse I felt about the
situation next level Sherlock security
briefings employee of business odds
workers such as yourself have many tools
of the trade without scalers paper
cutters fire extinguishers all can be
found in your work area please do not
misuse what you have been provided a
staple leaving a stapler can approach
speeds of mach 3 and fire extinguisher
foam can be incredibly corrosive certain
items can be used as special non rage
weapons with devastating effects watch
for the sparkling objects and try
throwing them or using them with the
left click in addition with our recent
purchase of boom color company every
employee will be provided with one free
soft drink these brand new flavours
developed by boom colors development of
weaponized refreshments division are not
yet available to the public forms will
be provided in case of any questionable
effects you may experience such as
suddenly being able to use both hands
Pressey to activate your perk for a
temporary ability soda machines twelve
packs and picture frames may contain
refills and remember boom Cola always
drink responsibly add an enhanced rate
okay
that seemed a really bizarre combined
with the demon magic that I found in the
last level I'm beginning to wonder what
this place is employing people for
alright this time I don't think I was
angry enough I don't think I channeled
Iggy in bravery so I'm gonna home Oh
what was that was it a skull
Oh God Oh bah this book makes ice
penises grow from the ground this is
very irresponsible this is supposed to
be a family friendly working environment
oh geez
yeah ah they should never have removed
Taco Tuesday that was obviously the
company's best day everyone always
looked forward to it and had a great
time when it was around
I know there are budgetary concerns but
come on we could have spared a little
for a company well-being burger maybe
throwing a harmless paper ball would be
okay I didn't mean to do that I'm sorry
what is that where did I pull this from
I mean I know I'm angry but I don't
think I'm angry enough to start [ __ ]
bats I'm just another time fired I think
I have other opportunities and maybe
like a professional sports career so I'm
just practicing
hope you guys don't mind I mean girl I
take what I want
um I'm a me I'm a bad boy
I'm a bad boy I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm
gonna I'm I do crimes whoo I'm I'm so
bad oh yeah what
I was in school I I skipped out on class
to go get ice cream yeah was so badass
what time my parents were like go to bed
and I was like no thirty more minutes
please and then I went to bed because
they said no yeah would anybody like
some pizza ah nothing that makes me
angrier than pizza sorry
okay I'm gonna I'm gonna leave now I
suppose okay goodbye I feel like this
has been a good outlet for my aggression
no one got hurt and no one will know
great I feel angrier ah I'm feeling like
this game is a little bit unhealthy it's
teaching very bad habits for the
children of today meet me being one of
those I'm 12
ratings employee of business and here
I'd like to talk to you about office
security
these are gather round a brand
watercoolers sponsored in part by
sherlock security feel free to gather
round and converse with your fellow
employees in the off chance any
disturbances are detected on the floor
these specialty coolers will send out
security box to apprehend and /
eliminate any potential issue you'll
never take me alive hahaha nor do they
intend to filling up your destruction
bar we'll also activate enemy spotters
if an enemy grabs ahold of you it can
result in an instant failure punch him
in the face to break free
our security coolers have many cool
functions and we give you a 99% chance
that secret listening devices are most
certainly not one and remember if any
employee is feeling a tad peckish food
has been provided on every floor just
don't forget to fill out a ration
requisition form for those tacos enemy
attacks will lower your health
destroying food such as tacos or Donuts
can drop health orbs now you're ready
for an exciting and rewarding career
have fun but more importantly don't ever
stop working should I start should I
stop working because since I've been
fired
all right this time I'm gonna really
give it to him I will really unleash my
aggression ah the comedy camping trip
was cancelled it makes me mad I only get
paid 1.5 times for overtime this is crap
oh ah the Christmas bonus was cut by a
third this year by company parking isn't
established correctly we should get
three weeks of paid vacation not to ah
why doesn't the health insurance plan
covered at all no it's always too hot
and winter and always too cold in the
summer it's [ __ ] it throws me off
oh no oh jeez oh that's mildly
terrifying I'm sorry for my one
destruction I'll I'll never do it again
oh oh geez I'm sorry sir I'm sorry have
a donut huh uh uh I think he's taking a
nap I can see he's still breathing
would you like a doughnut sir donut
donut donut oh geez oh geez oh geez oh
geez
ah oh ah I'm gonna get angry you guys to
back off I got a chair yeah oh you know
what the whole chair up you're mine oh
gee I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm
sorry you know sometimes I don't
remember that there are other employees
in here and I should really be
considerate of other people's feelings
at this juncture in time please get out
of the way oh that's not good oh I've
been oh no oh God I confess to
everything I'm I'm a victim of the
system no I had to lie I chose this path
and I'm very sorry for what I've done
don't tell my mom really I'm not a bad
boy I'm a good boy good guys game is
beat and it's for people who are also
bean huh okay I feel all right now I
feel like I vented some frustration and
and this is a healthy way to do it
because it's digital and it's not
actually real so no one
actually gets hurts but if if you have
any harsh feelings out there another
good outlet is to yell in the comments
randomly at everyone that passes by no
matter what they did or what they're
trying to do
just yell uncontrollably at them wait
anyway that was office freak out hope
you enjoyed that I feel distressed now I
feel like I could you know actually
break some office quitman in half but I
think I'll be okay I'll hold in my
aggression if I ever have to work a
cubicle job again which I have in the
past I'd probably do the same damn thing
so thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video bye bye
[Music]